From a World War II film about a dressed-up corpse
to a creepy horror comedy about a satanic child,
Netflix has a whole slew of hidden gems
that are just waiting to be discovered.
The best science-fiction tales aren't just
about unsure futures and alien worlds — they
also use new and unfamiliar environments to
point out universal truths about the human
condition. The script for Advantageous
is that kind of story. The film is set
in a technologically-advanced New York City
of tomorrow, where the divide between the
rich and the poor is more pronounced than
ever. As a result of this class struggle,
mothers will do absolutely anything to make
sure their children get an upper hand in life.
For Gwen, a wealthy cosmetic procedure salesperson
who gets fired right as her daughter enters an
expensive school, that means agreeing to be a test
subject for a painful procedure. The procedure
involves having her consciousness transferred
entirely into a new body. Complications arise,
calling into question whether or not this new
Gwen is even Gwen at all. In its review of
Advantageous, The Magazine of Fantasy and Science
Fiction called the film "quiet and affecting."
A young woman named Alice secretly
performs explicit acts as Lola_Lola,
camgirl extraordinaire. Though she's willing
to do whatever it takes to rise through the
ranks of popularity on her seedy hosting
site, Alice is able to keep an emotional
distance from her work — that is until a
dark contingent encourages her to perform
a shocking act of violence. In his review of
the film, Ty Burr of The Boston Globe wrote:
"Cam plays with both psychological horror
genre tropes and darker existential themes,
and its clear-eyed view of the drab
realities of a camgirl's life is
both refreshing and ultra-creepy."
A coming-of-age story about people
just trying to find their place in the world,
Dumplin' boasts a cast led by comedy legend
Jennifer Aniston and charismatic star-on-the-rise
Danielle Macdonald. The latter plays Willowdean
Dickson. She prefers to be called Will, but her
mother insists on referring to her as Dumplin'.
A supremely confident and witty teenager,
Dumplin' stands up for herself against bullies
who criticize her for her weight. Standing
up to her mother, however, is a lot harder.
So what better way to establish herself than
competing in her mother's beloved Miss Teen
Bluebonnet Pageant? What initially begins as
a protest against pageants and her mother,
soon becomes a celebration of all types
of beauty, thus prompting other overlooked
misfits to join Dumplin'. In her review of
the film, Elizabeth Weitzman of TheWrap wrote:
"This is a generous movie, and an
unrepentant fantasy at that, so it's
hard not to meet it with open heartedness."
Operation Mincemeat tells a fascinating and
gripping but little-known World War II
story, one so filled with audacious and
foolhardy participants that it's hard
to believe it's real. Set in 1943,
the Allied forces plan to stop Hitler's conquest
of Europe with a multi-pronged attack on Sicily,
a troubling option because it would ensure
mass casualties on both sides. And so, two
elite British intelligence officers come up with
a bizarre scheme, known as "Operation Mincemeat."
"Our other deception plans are
strategies designed to confuse the enemy,
throw him off balance. Mincemeat, on
the other hand, is an outright lie."
With plenty of help from higher-ups and the
rank-and-file, they dress up an abandoned corpse
in a Royal Marines uniform and plant evidence
of a false Allied invasion on it. From there,
the intelligence officers wait for the Axis
forces to discover the dressed-up corpse and
act accordingly on the misinformation. In his
rave of the film, Jake Wilson of The Age wrote:
"'Operation Mincemeat' is a genuine
surprise package — it prompts nostalgia,
if not for the war, then for an almost equally
distant era of skillfully crafted entertainment."
After expelling Belgian colonialists in 1960,
the Congo declared independence. So in 1961,
the United Nations arrived to help support the
newly formed government. U.N. peacekeeping troops
soon got caught up in a civil war between
the Democratic Republic of the Congo and
the natural resource-heavy secessionist
state of Katanga. The Siege of Jadotville
tells of a little-known moment in this seven-day
conflict, in which 3,000 mercenaries working for
mining companies in Katanga attacked the
150 Irish troops serving under the U.N.
Led by commandant Pat Quinlan, the
defense held its ground, pushing
back the thousands of attackers while waiting for
reinforcements to arrive. The film is a harrowing,
high-stakes drama, loaded with military action and
almost unbelievable acts of courage and tactical
brilliance. If you're a fan of war movies,
The Siege of Jadotville is not to be missed.
The fear of turning into one's parents as
they settle into adulthood is an extremely
common worry — it's also the basis for the
psychological-supernatural horror film Umma.
Amanda and her teenage daughter Chrissy
enjoy an idyllic existence on their farm,
hanging out and tending to bees. However,
everything changes when the remains of Amanda's
mother arrive from Korea. Umma wasn't a good mom —
she was cruel and abusive — and it was the reason
for a long estrangement. But what remains
of her bodily form literally haunts Amanda,
as she quickly evolves into her mother at her
most monstrous and horrific. While critics found
the film to be uneven, Umma is still worth
a watch. The film is original and quirky
while its unpredictable plot and character
choices subvert many horror movie cliches.
Dolemite is My Name may have been a huge
critical success when it was released in 2019,
but the movie's snubbing by the
Academy at that year's Oscars was
nothing less than scandalous.
So what's all the fuss about?
Dolemite is My Name tells the true story of Rudy
Ray Moore, comedian and Blaxploitation actor known
for his Dolemite movies. The movie covers Moore's
life during the period right before he became a
star through to when his first film opens in Los
Angeles. And Eddie Murphy, in a comeback of sorts,
does a truly outstanding job as Moore. According
to screenwriters Scott Alexander and Larry
Karaszewski, Murphy was their only choice for
the role, and they wrote the script with him
in mind. The three had met way back in 2003 and
bonded over their love of the real-life Moore.
"And tell him I want him out of here in
24 hours. And 23 of 'em are already gone."
Murphy's co-stars turn in some fine performances,
too. Wesley Snipes is wonderful playing
the director of Dolemite, D'Urville Martin,
and Da'Vine Joy Randolph is tremendous as
Lady Reed, Moore's long-time friend and
confidant. And then there are the costumes,
designed by Oscar-winner Ruth E. Carter,
which are as much the stars of Dolemite as the
actors themselves. Swagger, thy name is Dolemite.
Written and directed by Macon Blair, I Don't
Feel at Home in this World Anymore is a comedy
thriller starring Melanie Lynskey and Elijah
Wood. The movie is about a woman, recently
robbed of a laptop, who joins her oddball neighbor
in trying to track it down when the police won't
do anything about it. They quickly end up in way
over their heads, and mayhem inevitably ensues.
Blair's double duty as writer and director works
well here. He's crafted a tight standalone movie
that feels like a throwback to the sort of
low-budget, quirky independent features that
so rarely get attention these days. Lynskey's
performance as Ruth is pretty terrific too,
bringing life to the "everywoman" who has finally
had enough. And then there's Wood, who has, in the
past few years, excelled at playing the weirdo
— and his role as Tony here is no exception.
Based on Bernard Cornwell's The Saxon
Stories, the Netflix series The Last
Kingdom is a historical drama about King Alfred
the Great. The show blends actual events from
the 9th century with fiction in order to tell the
story of Alfred's unification of the Anglo-Saxon
kingdoms. At the outset of the series, this land
has been conquered and captured by the Vikings,
with only King Alfred and his Kingdom
of Wessex standing in their way.
In particular, The Last Kingdom
follows Uhtred of Bebbanburg,
a noble Saxon who is kidnapped as a slave and
then raised by the Danes. Uhtred is subsequently
forced to choose between the people that
raised him and the land of his birth.
The Last Kingdom has everything you'd
want in a historical drama covering this
time period — brutal fighting, great
characters, intriguing storylines and
some gorgeous cinematography. And all those
English accents? Well, they're just a bonus.
Netflix made its first major foray into
original films when it acquired Beasts of
No Nation. Directed by True Detective vet Cary
Fukunaga,it tells the harrowing, powerful tale
of a West African child caught in a civil war and
recruited to a rebel militia as a child soldier.
Idris Elba gives a commanding—and
terrifying—performance as the militia
leader who orders his soldiers to
perform ever more horrific acts.
Another winner from Netflix's
stable of original films,
The Fundamentals of Caring takes the "road
movie" formula and gives it an offbeat twist.
“Ahhhhh, help me, help me, Ahhhhh!”
Paul Rudd and Craig Roberts team up
as, respectively,a caretaker and a
teen afflicted with muscular dystrophy
out to explore the country and themselves
(while picking up a hitchhiking
Selena Gomez along the way).
Writer-director Rob Burnett's deft touch with the
material makes for an enjoyably diverting journey.
It’s a story you’ll probably
feel like you’ve heard before:
a nuclear reactor goes haywire after a
devastating earthquake, endangering the
citizens of a small South Korean town. As various
government officials try to escape the blame,
the ordinary folk do their best to avoid the
cataclysmic destruction of the reactor itself.
So far, so bland, right? Well, stick around,
because towards the end Pandora suddenly
transforms into something so beautiful and
touching that you can't help but wonder if
Netflix's autoplay switched movies without
you noticing. The rest of Pandora is decent
enough, but that ending is one for the ages.
Airplanes are an ideal and almost infinitely
reusable setting for horror movies. After all,
a passenger jet is a giant metal box hurtling
through the sky at tremendous and dangerous
speeds and disconnected from the regular
world. If there are monsters on a plane,
it's kind of hard to run away
or call up the authorities.
And that's where "Blood Red Sky" begins. At
first, it seems like a standard — if extremely
intense — hijacking drama. But these kinds of
films always have an unlikely hero on board who
saves the day. In this case, it's Nadja, a German
single mother seemingly suffering from leukemia
who boards a long-haul flight to New York with
her young son, Elias. When terrorists violently
take over control of the flight, it's Nadja who
fights back, and it quickly becomes clear that her
illness isn't cancer. Rather, it's something
akin to a progressive and aggressive form of
vampirism. The result is a bloody good time. Or as
Randy Myers of the San Jose Mercury News put it,
"Director co-writer Peter Thorwarth splatters
the screen with gore while tossing in surprise,
delirious preposterousness, and even a
few touching moments. It's grand fun."
An introspective and action-packed MMA tale
both starring and directed by Halle Berry,
"Bruised" is something special.
The Oscar-winner plays Jackie "Pretty Bull"
Justice, a once-great brawler who forfeits
a fight and retires a pariah. Still emotionally
smarting from her ignominious exit years later,
she follows the advice of her boyfriend/manager
and agrees to participate in an underground
fight ring that could lead her back to
the top. All of this single-minded focus
on career and winning gets complicated,
however, when her estranged son reappears
on her doorstep. Kevin Maher of The
Times sums "Bruised" up by saying,
"[The film is] rescued at almost every turn
by Berry's fearless, vanity-free turn."
"Coffee and Kareem" is about
a clashing, mismatched pair,
and the film itself is a clashing,
mismatched set of movie styles all
ramming into each other. The end
result is full of action, comedy,
and even heart. Ed Helms of "The Office" portrays
incompetent Detroit police officer James Coffee,
who begins dating single mother Vanessa, much to
the consternation of her 12-year-old son, Kareem.
To scare off the kind and doting Coffee, Kareem
tries to hire a criminal to intimidate the cop,
but winds up embroiling them both in a massive,
extremely dangerous conspiracy involving
drug lords and crooked police officers.
"I know it's hard to believe,
but most cops are good people."
"Spoken like a true white man."
Guillermo del Toro is a masterful writer and
director, specializing in fantasy and horror
and where those two imaginative genres intersect.
A double Oscar winner for his work on "The Shape
of Water," del Toro also made emerging classics
like "Pan's Labyrinth" and "Hellboy." But in 2015,
he directed a lesser-known fright fest called
"Crimson Peak," a gothic tale that didn't get
much love when it came out. Even still, this
haunted house story is definitely worth a watch.
In 19th-century Victorian England, a young
American woman named Edith marries the dashing
Sir Thomas Sharpe and goes off to live in his
sprawling mansion in the English countryside. But
something doesn't feel quite right about the home
or Sir Thomas' creepy sister. And when Edith's
abilities to speak with and see the dead manifest,
she learns the truth behind her spooky visions and
the family into which she probably shouldn't
have just married. Film writer Richard Crouse
called the film, quote, "bloody terrifying,"
while Trace Thurman of Bloody Disgusting said,
"You'll be mesmerized by what
you're seeing on screen."
Supernatural menai ce is scary, but
so is the dark side of daily life,
not to mention horrific trauma.
All those elements converge in
"His House," the 2020 debut feature
film from writer-director Remi Weekes.
Bol and Rial escape wartime South Sudan and
then take a crowded boat with other refugees,
making it from France to England, where they're
allowed to stay and given a rotting house to live
in. Facing openly racist neighbors and threats of
deportation, the couple attempts to embrace their
newfound Britishness and make a go of the new
normal. Unfortunately, the house is inhabited
by pure evil, and a vengeful witch sends the
duo grasping for their lives and even reality.
There's a lot going on in "His House," and
almost all of it will provoke some kind
of emotional reaction from viewers. Tim
Grierson of Screen International writes,
"The film has much to say about
grief, guilt, assimilation,
and the ongoing refugee crisis. And on top of
all that, it's also a nifty nerve-jangler."
Robert Daniels of Polygon claims,
"[The film] breathes a fresh voice
into the haunted house subgenre."
Based on the comic book of the same name by
Charles Forsman, "I Am Not Okay with This" is the
story of a 17-year-old girl who is trying to deal
with high school, the death of her dad, and her
newly discovered superpowers. Sydney realizes that
when she has an emotional outburst, as teenagers
are prone to do, she is able to move objects.
In addition to finding out she is telekinetic,
she is also trying to manage the feelings she
has for both of her friends, Dina and Stan.
"Can we please stick together?"
"Duh, I'd never leave you."
Sophia Lillis is terrific in her role as Sydney.
Since her appearance in 2017's "IT," the young
actress has proven herself in projects like
"Gretel and Hansel" and "Uncle Frank," and
"I Am Not Okay with This" is yet another step in
her rise to stardom. This seven-episode Netflix
original series is sure to be easily relatable to
anyone who went through an awkward teenage past.
Here's a wildly different and unpredictable movie
that merges together movie genres that often rely
so heavily on tropes that they're overly familiar
and predictable. "In the Shadow of the Moon"
is part sci-fi movie, part mystery, and part
serial killer story. The film begins in 1988,
when Philadelphia police officer Thomas Lockhart
is desperately trying to find and stop a prolific
murderer whose victims seem to lose all of
their blood at once. They find the suspect,
Rya, but she evades capture by
falling to her apparent death.
Flash forward nine years, and Rya is
killing again. Then another nine years,
and more murders occur. Thomas becomes
the obsessed detective, researching the
case for decades as his quest leads him down the
unexpected crime-fighting path of time travel.
Chris Vognar of the New York Times says,
"['In the Shadow of the Moon' is] never less than
engaging, and it's just about always clever."
Adherents of thie dystopian sci-fi boom of the
2010s — both of the literary and film version of
stuff like "The Maze Runner" and "The Hunger
Games" — will find a lot to like in "Level
16." The action centers around the students at an
extremely bleak, sedate, and colorless residential
girls-only boarding school. The enrolled
young women are actually more like prisoners,
and they've been at this school since they
were infants, when they lived on Level 0. Now,
as Sophia and Vivien are 16-years-old and live
on Level 16, they start to question their strange
lives. It's up to Sophia and Vivien to learn
the true nature of their school — and their very
existence — if they want to escape.Film writer
Richard Crouse commented on the film, saying,
"Mixing elements of social
justice, horror and sci fi,
“Level 16” is a genre movie that delivers
both intellectually and emotionally."
Be careful what you wish for, "Nightbooks" subtly
suggests, because wishes just might be real. Or
at least magic is — and it's a powerful and
oppressive source if placed in the wrong hands.
Alex is a little kid who loves to write scary
stories until other kids call him weird for it,
and he endeavors to never write again. Not long
after, a happily wicked and very stylish witch
traps him in her magical, traveling, all-consuming
townhouse and orders him to write her a scary
story each night ... or she'll kill him. Alex
teams up with another of the witch's young
captives, Yasmin, to survive and find a way out of
the villain's clutches by defeating the powerful
magic that's all around them. Looper's own Matthew
Jackson shared his thoughts on the film, sharing,
"[It's] not just an effective little family horror
adventure, but an ode to weird kids everywhere."
"That's good. Really good. Thanks."
Horror movies are most effective in delivering
truly visceral and bewildered responses from
audiences when they speak to deep-seated,
widespread fears. They become relatable on
a deep, even subliminal level, and great
horror filmmakers use tropes like ghosts,
monsters, and other supernatural phenomena
as allegories for what truly can eat us
alive. That's what's going on in "No One
Gets Out Alive," a Netflix Original from
visual effects creator turned first-time
feature director Santiago Menghini.
Ambar is an undocumented immigrant living
in a rundown, women-only boarding house in
Cleveland. Beyond the physical disrepair,
there's a bigger creepiness to the place,
which becomes clear when the ghosts of previous
borders start to frighten Ambar. But since she's
living in the U.S. illegally, she can't seek
out the help of authorities or find refuge
elsewhere because she fears deportation. "No
One Gets Out Alive" is a haunted house story,
but it's really about the plight of recent
immigrants trying to survive in a new country.
"The Old Ways" is a haunting thriller about
haunting things. Partially in English and
partially in Spanish, it's a horror movie
that blends traditional and familiar elements
of classic horror movies with Mexican folklore
and tales of witchcraft. Brigitte Kali Canales
portrays Cristina Lopez, a Mexican-American
reporter who heads back to her hometown,
near Veracruz on the Gulf of Mexico, to research
a story about the area's many witchy legends. Her
information gathering quickly turns from
academic into something much darker and
hands-on when a collection of local residents
kidnap and hold her against her will. The Bruja
means to use her powers to rid Cristina of
the demon the group believes possesses her.
Michael Talbot-Haynes of Film Threat praised "The
Old Ways" as the best exorcism movie
since "The Exorcist," while Deirdre
Crimmins of Rue Morgue Magazine found it
to be an all-around good and scary movie.
"Red Dot" is an action movie broken down into its
most basic elements. It's about two people in an
unfamiliar environment being chased by an unknown
party trying to kill them for unknown reasons. The
film starts out with Nadja and David, a couple
expecting a baby but otherwise disconnected,
who embark on a hiking getaway in snowy
northern Sweden. After some awkward and
unsettling encounters with locals, Nadja
and David soon find themselves desperately
trying to survive brutally violent and
surreptitious attackers. Eventually,
the deadly game of human hunting all makes sense,
but viewers will enjoy putting together the tragic
pieces. Jade Budowski of Decider says "Red Dot"
is, quote, "tense, disturbing, and well-made."
Dave Franco is primarily known as an actor
in comedic films like "The Disaster Artist"
and "21 Jump Street." But as a screenwriter and
first-time director with "The Rental," he shows
his filmmaking ambitions can veer to the sinister
and the tried-and-true hallmarks of horror.
*Woman screaming in car*
"The Rental" explores the slight creepiness
that can come with temporarily living
in the home of someone else. It also
takes the idea to its darkest depths,
exploiting the unsettling feelings
of isolation that can accompany a
weekend getaway. Married couple Charlie and
Michelle, along with dating pair Josh and Mina,
rent a remote beach house for a few days. But
when they arrive, things feel a little off,
particularly because someone is spying on the
foursome and slowly, carefully hunting them
down. And it might not even be the rude, racist
property owner. Wenlei Ma of Australia's News.com,
"Delivering solid thrills and an ugly
portrait of disintegrating relationships,
'The Rental' is a clever
meld of drama and horror."
Likewise, Susan Kamyab of This
Chix Flix called the film,
"A solid thriller that subtly goes from
nerve-racking drama to shocking slasher."
"The Ritual" plays off the "lost in the
woods" scenario while introducing new and
innovative elements to the well-established
subgenre of scary forest flicks. Four old
college buddies seek comfort and connection after
the unexpected death of a fifth friend. They go
out hiking in a rural area in Scandinavia and
encounter ancient, poorly understood, and deeply
evil forces that wish them harm. "The Ritual,"
according to Alan Scherstuhl of the Village Voice,
"Achieves a tense and devilish power,
leaving you in the dark with these guys."
Katie Walsh of the Los Angeles
Times said of the film,
"[It's] efficient and highly effective in its
style, relying on sound, creepy production design,
and the men's own fear and misjudgment
to create the sense of pervasive doom."
Not much sleep happens in "The Sleepover"
— it's a heist movie and a kidnapping caper
with a switcheroo in that it's the kids who
need to save the grown-ups. It's one of those
movies where tweens get to stay up all night and
go on a grand adventure. Goofy mother Margot was
once an intentional master thief, who quit that
life, entered witness protection, and married
her dweeby husband Ron. The past comes back to
haunt her when her old team recruits her — by
way of kidnapping her and Ron — and forces her to
help them steal a precious crown from a dignitary.
"Your mom is getting cooler by, like, the second."
When Margot and Ron's kids come home to an
empty house, they figure out their mother's
secret life and potential whereabouts
and set out to rescue her with the aid
of criminal and spy gadgetry she left behind.
"Small Crimes" is a small crime movie about people
on the fringes of society who have seemingly
resigned themselves to life on the edge. It's an
interesting and unsettling take on the
crime-drama genre. Nikolaj Coster-Waldau
plays a fallen-from-grace police officer just
emerging from prison after serving six years
for attempted murder. He wants to get his life
on track and redeem himself with his family, but
they don't want much to do with him. This helps to
send him headlong back into a world of corruption,
organized crime, casual violence, and other seedy
elements. Mike D'Angelo of The AV Club said,
"If the film came across as jaded and cynical,
it might well be hard to take. Instead,
it seems weary and defeated, as if
some people are simply born to fail."
Netflix definitely knew what it was doing when it
snagged this little story for a screen adaptation.
Based on a novella from Stephen King's Full
Dark, No Stars anthology, 1922 stars Thomas
Jane as Wilfred James, a farmer living in rural
Nebraska during the period leading up to the Great
Depression. Money troubles and marital conflict
lead Wilfred to some very dark places—and it
just goes to show that sometimes, getting away
with a crime is much worse than getting caught.
"I'd murdered my wife to keep my home. The only
way I was leavin’ it now would be in chains."
Like many of Stephen King's best works,
this is a character-driven horror,
and strong performances make it a
standout—particularly from Jane,
who immerses himself in the role so thoroughly
that it's hard to believe this same miserable,
hay-chewing yokel is the same cosmopolitan
pretty boy from The Sweetest Thing.
"You're never gonna find anyone better than my
brother here. He is the greatest and I am serious.
Just look at him. Chicks freak on this guy."
In 2014, filmmaker Patrick Brice set out to
answer the question "What's the worst thing that
could happen from meeting someone on Craigslist?"
Without spoiling anything, let's just say that
the answer is something really bad. That's what
a videographer discovers when he goes to
the home of Josef—played by Mark Duplass,
who also co-wrote and produced the movie—for
what's supposed to be a documentary project. What
starts out as the ordinary weirdness of internet
strangers becomes something much more disturbing.
"Oh that's Peach Fuzz… That’s
just Peach Fuzz. Say hello."
The result is a movie that more
than lives up to its title.
With so many blockbusters the big screen
in 2017, you might have missed some of the
smaller adaptations of Stephen King's
works—including this one based on the
1992 novel of the same name. Gerald's Game
centers on a woman named who ends up trapped,
handcuffed to the bed at her lake house
after her husband has a heart attack. As
she struggles to find a way to escape, she's
visited by a series of entities—some real,
some imagined, and some that seem to straddle
the line between this world and the next.
"Who are you?"
One of Netflix's original feature films,
Gerald's Game was eagerly anticipated by
hardcore King fans but didn't get the kind of
widespread attention merited by its creativity
and star power. Despite the obvious challenges of
holding down an entire two-hour film on her own,
actress Carla Gugino keeps it riveting,
making this the finest horror movie set
almost entirely on a bed since, well, maybe
ever. Unless you count Bed of the Dead.
Have you ever had a nightmare that comes
true? If so, you might be intrigued by
the premise of the film Extinction.
That's exactly what happens to Peter,
who begins having bad dreams about an
invading force that comes to Earth,
threatening the safety of his family and
everything he holds dear. Little does he know
that these disturbing nightmares would actually
turn out to be premonitions. When he visits a
psychiatrist to get to the root of these dreams,
he encounters another patient who's been suffering
from the same night terrors, and he begins to
wonder if there is something bigger going on.
"What if something bad is
coming and this is like a sign?"
Unfortunately, Peter's suspicions
prove to be correct: one night,
spaceships suddenly descend upon the city and
attack. Peter and his wife manage to snag a
weapon from one of the invading soldiers, and
Peter utilizes the knowledge from his visions
to protect his family — but his understanding
of what's actually happening can only get them
so far. Peter is about to discover that he
was receiving these visions for a reason,
and when he finds out why, the
knowledge turns his life upside down.
A sequel to 2010's Skyline, which followed
survivors of an alien invasion of Los Angeles,
Beyond Skyline explores another story taking
place at the same time as the original movie.
In this film, Los Angeles police detective
Mark Corley helps his son Trent get out of
jail just as the invasion begins.
Mark and Trent are estranged,
but Mark couldn't stand to leave his son
behind. As most of the residents of LA are
sucked up into various spaceships by huge beams
of light, Mark leads a group of stray survivors
through the subway tunnels to the marina, hoping
to escape to somewhere safe. But, of course,
their plan doesn't work out the way they had
hoped. When they finally make it to the marina,
they're captured by the alien flagship —
and that's when the real adventure begins.
What's actually happening inside these
ships, and what do these creatures
want from human beings? Mark is about to
stumble on some truly disturbing answers.
In just a few short years, director Yeon Sang-ho's
Train to Busan has become a modern zombie classic.
With that kind of pedigree, you'd think that
his 2018 fantasy-superhero mashup Psychokinesis
would have made more waves, but sadly it
slipped under the current for most people.
When a despondent security guard unknowingly
drinks water tainted by some sort of mystical
meteor juice, he suddenly gains the power
to move things around with his mind. With
his newfound abilities, he sets out to
reconnect with his estranged daughter.
While it takes awhile to get going,
Psychokinesis rewards viewers with an
epic finale that makes the whole journey
worthwhile, and proves again that Yeon
is as skilled behind the camera as he is
at writing heartfelt, emotional stories.
Fashion designer Tom Ford scripted
and directed Nocturnal Animals,
a mind-bending, and deeply unsettling thriller
in which the plot itself blends, interferes,
and gets confused with a story being told by the
film's troubled characters. Amy Adams plays Susan,
an unhappily married art gallery owner who
receives a fascinating novel manuscript called
Nocturnal Animals, written by her vindictive
first husband, Edward, played by Jake Gyllenhaal.
The action in the film shifts to depict the book,
a horrifying story about Tony, also portrayed by
Gyllenhaal, a man whose car breaks down in rural
Texas just before a gang of criminals kidnaps his
wife and daughter and leaves him stranded. It's
up to Detective Bobby Andes, a strong-but-silent
type to help Tony exact his revenge.
Meanwhile, back in Susan and Edward's world,
viewers learn about the emotional devastation
that led to the demise of their marriage.
Neil Pond of Parade called Nocturnal Animals an...
"Arty and grotesquely gorgeous, but hardly an
uplifting tale. [...] Think No Country For Old
Men meets CSI: West Texas, by way of Twin Peaks."
A Monster Calls might sound like the name of a
horror movie, but it's actually a Spielberg-like
fantasy. Director J.A. Bayona crafts an
allegorical, eye-popping film about all-too
real and difficult emotions from the point
of a view of a child, which makes it all the more
heartbreaking. A Monster Calls is about grief,
but it's also about a walking, talking,
tree creature with the voice of Liam Neeson.
Conor is 13, and his mother is dying. He's
just old enough to know what's going on,
but young enough to have no idea how
to cope; he can't turn to his stern
grandmother for help and his father isn't
a big part of his life. An unlikely and
impossible ally arrives just when Conor
needs him: He is the Monster, a massive,
sentient yew tree who offers to tell Conor three
grand tales. After that, Conor must share his own.
"Stories are wild creatures, Conor
O'Malley. When you let them loose,
who knows what havoc they may wreak?"
It's all a little frightening and also
wonderful, and the revelation of where
the tree learned his stories will definitely
leave the viewer misty-eyed, which is rare
for a movie about a giant monster who may or
may not be a figment of a child's imagination.
Television has been graced with many reality and
game shows that pit a group of strangers against
each other, requiring a vote to eliminate all but
one last-standing champion. Alliances are formed,
but it's ultimately every person for themselves.
The provocative and frightening 2015 film Circle
takes the idea and ups the stakes considerably. 50
strangers, all facing execution, are placed in a
darkened room and made to choose among themselves
which one of them get to walk out alive.
"It's us."
"Us?"
"What do you mean?"
"We're choosing who dies."
The sparse film's sparse 87
minutes fly by as various unnamed,
desperate characters passionately argue and
bargain on behalf of their own futures while
time and chances run out. Of course, they
also have to fear immediate eradication by
the wicked forces holding them in
the room if they so much as move.
John DeFore of The Hollywood Reporter
wrote about the film, saying...
"[Circle] keeps suspense alive, building
to a final tableau that, silently,
says nearly as much about human nature
as does all the talk leading up to it."
An elite squad of secret operatives hunting down
and punishing those who committed unspeakable
acts of terror against their community is a
small film genre unto itself — and a good one
at that. Among such stories, one can find as
much action and drama as cathartic psychology
and shocking real-world history. In the
same vein of Steven Spielberg's Munich,
which told the story of Israeli Mossad
agents going after the terrorists who
killed athletes at the 1972 Summer
Olympics, comes Operation Finale.
The film details the early '60s
mission of a team of highly-trained,
top secret Israeli operatives who travel to
Argentina in order to bring to justice Adolf
Eichmann. He was a high-ranking Nazi official
who masterminded the logistics of the Holocaust,
responsible for the deaths of millions
of Jewish people. Oscar Isaac plays
real-life Mossad agent Peter Malkin,
leading the charge against Eichmann.
M.V. Moorhead of Phoenix
Magazine called Operation Finale…
"Crisp and absorbing and satisfying,
both as a thriller and as a moral drama."
On one level, viewers know exactly what
they're getting when they click on a
movie called Vampires vs. the Bronx.
"We got vampires in the Bronx."
It is indeed a violent tale of creepy
bloodsuckers hailing from Eastern Europe,
in the classic vampire movie style. But this
time, they're in a modern-day urban setting,
specifically one of New York City's five boroughs.
However, Vampires vs. the Bronx is so much more
than that — it's a socially conscious celebration
of Bronx culture, the story of a bunch of smart
and capable kids coming together to save the
day, and a deeply satirical horror-comedy.
The vampiric real estate agents at
the center of the story represent
wealthy individuals and businesses that
want to gentrify older neighborhoods,
and a scrappy bunch of young people have to stop
them before nothing is left and no one is alive.
"Don't go there, Ma."
"He's...he's a really bad man."
"Of course he is, he's in real estate."
Like many critics, Ben Travis
of Empire had positive things
to say about Vampires vs. the
Bronx. He called the film...
"A witty and likable horror-comedy that manages to
put a stake to the heart of some real
issues while it tickles your ribs."
Based on Joe Ballarini's series of gently
spooky kids novels of the same name,
The Babysitter's Guide to Monster Hunting is a
family-friendly movie directed by Rachel Talalay,
a filmmaker best known for her work on Tank
Girl and the Nightmare on Elm Street series.
Ballarini and Talalay were the ideal combo to
make what could be a kid's first horror-comedy,
a dark, funny, and twisted take on the
'80s classic Adventures in Babysitting.
Teenage babysitter Kelly gets a gig looking after
a kid on Halloween night. That's a bummer in and
of itself, made worse when the child is kidnapped
by the actual Boogeyman. Kelly has to do her best
to rescue the little guy. Luckily, she's helped
along the way in her fight against monsters,
goblins, and pure evil by a secret society
of elite and well-equipped babysitters.
"Ugh, I hate babysitters."
Nell Minnow of Movie Mom said the film delivers...
"Gorgeously imagined settings, a great cast,
and an exciting story that hits the exact sweet
spot between funny-scary and scary-funny."
The best horror movies consist of a
lot more than just a few jump scares
and some terrifying form of bone-chilling
menace — the good ones reflect and comment
upon the everyday things that trouble human
beings. Little Evil is that kind of movie.
It's a horror-comedy, with the emphasis on
comedy, about an eager-to-please guy who
marries a woman who has a son from a previous
marriage. He's desperate to connect with the
inscrutable little guy so his relationship
can thrive and they can all come together
as a happy family. That's a difficult task,
as the kid is actually the spawn of Satan
and he's not afraid to unleash pure evil and
terror on his well-meaning new stepdad. And
that's where the horror comes into play; that,
and with a creepy hand-puppet named Reeroy.
"I'm your step-father now."
"Get out."
"Yeah, okay. We'll just talk
later or whenever you want."
Amanda Sink of The Hollywood Outsider
perfectly described the film in one line.
"Little Evil is [The] Omen
by way of Shaun of the Dead."
If you've never watched much Bollywood, it
may be hard to tell if Makkhi is making fun
of those films or comfortably nestled
at the heart of it all. The absurdity
feels intentionally cranked to 11, but then
again, there's also a distinct possibility
that a song-and-dance number followed by a
Rocky training montage for a reincarnated
fly is completely normal. Either way,
it's totally worth your time to watch.
Here's the premise, and it's a doozy: A fly
born from the soul of a dead man goes on a
revenge rampage against the guy who killed
him. It's John Wick crossed with A Bug's
Life crossed with…uhhh...La-La-Land? Maybe?
There's a trippy Ant-Man vibe to the visuals
and explosive action sequences, all tied
into a deathmatch between a man and, well,
a housefly. As far as hidden gems go, this
one's like stumbling across a dead unicorn
in the woods. It's majestic. And you just
don't know what the hell to do with it.
There seem to be two camps when it comes to
this Netflix animated film — those who like the
original manga hate the movie, and those who
haven't read the manga generally enjoyed it.
But love it or hate it, when it comes
to fresh takes on the apocalypse,
Blame! has most any other futuristic vision
beat, hands down. That's what makes this
film so intriguing. In a seemingly endless,
continually growing city that goes for miles up,
down, and in either direction, robots
have taken to exterminating humans. But
a small band of people has survived for
centuries inside an invisible shield that
keeps the robots out. They don't know why
the robots can't get inside their colony;
they just know that going outside means risking
life and limb at the hands of predatory robots.
It's only when a stranger comes to
their town that they realize there
may be a chance to do something about
their predicament and finally stop
the expansion of the city. For vision
alone, Blame! is well worth watching.
Is the live-action version of Fullmetal
Alchemist as good as the anime? Not even
close. Is it cheesy and hilarious and
full of ridiculous moments? Oh, you bet.
For newcomers to the whole thing,
the story is about two brothers with
a natural inclination for alchemy who
attempt to bring their mother back to
life. Things go horribly wrong, and one
brother ends up with his soul trapped in
a suit of armor while the other loses
an arm and a leg. When they're older,
they search for the mythical philosopher's
stone in the hopes of restoring their bodies.
As far as anime adaptations go, Fullmetal
Alchemist is arguably one of the best out
there. It doesn't cover the whole
story, but it serves as an origin
tale and works as a self-contained story
that even non-fans can enjoy. At least,
you can enjoy it if you already like over-the-top
action fantasies. That's all this is.
Maniac is hard to categorize. It's a darkly
comic, often surreal and lightly dystopian
miniseries set in a future world where gadgetry
and pharmaceuticals have rapidly progressed,
but a 1980s consumer tech flavor permeates
the design of day-to-day life. Desperate and
guilt-ridden Annie and troubled rich family black
sheep Owen lock down for a heavily controlled
psychological drug trial at a mysterious drug
company operated by the eccentric Dr. James K.
Mantleray. Mantleray is literally and explicitly
in love with machinery who lives in the shadow of
his mother, Dr. Greta Mantleray, a popular
pop psychologist and best-selling author.
That all fuses with journeys deep into the minds
of Owen and Annie -- and sometimes both at once,
when their subconscious realities intersect
-- who live out their deepest fears and
insecurities in disparate ways, such as
an exotic animal heist and a Lord of the
Rings-esque fantasy. Not only dazzling and
challenging, Maniac is visually stunning,
psychologically dense, and often
surprisingly emotional all at once. .
Rim of the World director McG
unabashedly and cheerfully made
an '80s-style kid adventure movie. Rim
of the World mixes elements of E.T.,
The Goonies, and Red Dawn to create a similarly
fun sci-fi action movie where teens save the day.
"If you find yourself alone, riding
in green fields with the sun on your
face, do not be troubled. For you are
in Elysium. And you are already dead."
The simple, irresistible premise: four kids arrive
at summer camp just in time for an invasion of the
planet by wicked aliens. With the well-populated
"Rim of the World" camp soon abandoned, it's up to
this ragtag group of teens who don't quite fit
in elsewhere to come together and thwart what
amounts to the end of the world. They'll have to
do it all without adults, computers, or much of
anything… except, of course, for bikes. Heaven
of Horror says of this lightweight diversion:
"This is an absolute treat for fans of sci-fi,
adventure, action, and monster movies."
After bringing so much attention and accolades
to Netflix via his unforgettable performance as
Sheriff Hopper on Stranger Things, it's no
surprise that David Harbour has free reign
to do whatever he wants at the streaming
giant. And what he wants to do is a meta,
sci-fi and horror-laced mockumentary about
his life, a collaboration with Arrested
Development writer John Levenstein. The result
is a short special that's a bit hard to define.
Frankenstein's Monster's Monster, Frankenstein is
based around a mid-1970s made-for-TV production
of the two-man theatrical version of Frankenstein.
The twist is that Harbour plays his own "father,"
also an actor named David Harbour, as the
two generations play both Dr. Frankenstein
and his monstrous creation at the same time. To
round out this tribute from the younger Harbour
to the fictional older Harbour are clips of the
actor from other vintage fictitious productions
like The Crying Detective and The Actor's Trunk.
The whole thing winds up both a love letter to
the craft of acting and an affectionate send-up of
the entire notion of playing pretend for a living.
Vietnam is home to a quickly developing movie
culture and industry, and the action thriller
Furie teams up two of its stars, director
Le-Van Kiet and actress Veronica Ngo, best
known to Western audiences as gunner Paige
Tico in Star Wars: The Last Jedi. In Furie,
Ngo portrays a former criminal overlord who now
works as the muscle for a loan shark in the city
of Can Tho, shaking down delinquents
with a shattering of a kneecap or two.
That violence comes home to roost when her
daughter, Mai, is kidnapped and seemingly
sold to black market organ dealers. Ngo,
propelled by equal parts rage, guilt,
and love, takes to the seedy sides of Ho Chi
Minh City to get her daughter back in one piece.
Furie is a tight, often sparse ride,
which includes plenty of novel set pieces,
beautiful cinematography, and
an intense motorbike chase.
Sometimes the scariest parts of a scary
movie don't come from monsters or gore,
but from menace and dread. That's what
propels the precisely paced Earthquake Bird,
based on the novel of the same name by Susanna
Jones. Alicia Vikander of Ex Machina returns
to the kind of moody, unsettling cinema that made
her famous, portraying Lucy, a Swedish expatriate
who has settled into a life in 1989 Tokyo that is
repetitive, bland, and mundane. It's by design,
as she's looking to flee from and forget
past traumas. She works as a translator,
living alone while maintaining some low-key
friendships and playing cello in a string quartet.
One day, Lucy meets Teiji, a noodle shop worker
and aspiring photographer. She enchants
him and lets him make portraits of her.
"I've never had my picture
taken before. Not properly."
"Then, I'm the first."
But just when it seems like her
icy veneer is starting to thaw,
Lucy's life is interrupted by
a brash American named Lily,
who goes missing and is presumed dead. Is
the mysterious Lucy responsible, either
via conscious act or her status as a tragedy
magnet? Or is she merely an unreliable narrator?
Gabriel Silver of the Detroit Metro Times said:
"Earthquake Bird is an enjoyable neo-noir film,
with enough twists and turns to leave
you thinking long after the ending."
According to the thoughtful sci-fi movie Io,
humanity is doomed to never change its ways,
and in the not-too-distant future, Earth
becomes uninhabitable. Fortunately,
scientists have found a new home for mankind
on Io, one of Jupiter's many moons. A scientist
named Sam is among the handful of humans
who haven't made the migration to Io yet,
staying behind to test the water and
air for signs of decreasing toxicity,
as well as to raise bees that she hopes
could someday pollinate and help save the
planet's vegetation. Time is running out,
and certain catastrophic events lead Sam
to head with another survivor, Micah, to
a shuttle that will take them into space.
Io is full of philosophical and mental tension as
these two bear witness to what could
be Earth's final, extinctive whimper,
but also a newfound hope for the future.
Leigh Monson of Birth.Movies.Death. says:
"If you're looking for science fiction that
makes manifest the anxieties of a dying world,
our dying world, then Io
is a good place to start."
"We weren't ready for this. No matter what
warning we got from people like your father."
What if John Wick was more violent, more
nihilistic, and with a gleeful undercurrent
of shock humor and an honest exploration of the
mental effects of a violent life? That's Polar,
the messy story of one man's quest to relax
and secure his pension. Mads Mikkelsen,
the Danish actor best known for his starring
role on the stylish TV version of Hannibal,
stars as Duncan Vizla, a highly effective assassin
forced by his corporate bosses to retire at age
50 and enjoy his golden years. Of course, his
company plans to kill him off to avoid funding
his payout. From a lovely cabin in Montana, Duncan
has to fight off some violent attacks while also
dealing with PTSD and forging a friendship
with a neighbor with demons of her own.
Groundhog Day may seem like a comedy, but it's
actually a horror movie. Seriously: A guy is such
a nasty person that the universe spontaneously
conspires to make him shape up by sticking him
in a time loop from which he cannot escape.
That's a living nightmare. ARQ takes Groundhog
Day for the horror movie it is and runs with it.
Robbie Amell stars as an engineer responsible
for a world-changing technology, only to find
himself dealing with a home invasion brought on
by bad dudes who want his technology for their own
means. Our protagonist gets stuck in a time loop,
forcing him to experience his horrible situation
over and over again, until he can find a way out.
"Today is repeating. Tell me you
remember. Come on, you have to remember."
"Have you lost your fucking f—ing mind?"
Life in an especially dingy and crime-filled
part on London is rough for Tom, a shy and
awkward teenager who just wants to go about
his business and maybe take things to the next
level with his friend Lucy. When he goes over to
her apartment to study together, he's greeted
by thugs who have just savagely attacked Lucy
and her brother. Tom runs away and tries to
call the police, only for the thugs to shoot
him in the head and leave him for dead.
The good news: He survived! The bad news:
He wakes up two days after the attack with bits
of his phone stuck inside in his severely damaged
noggin. Luckily, like some kind of Silicon Valley
Spider-Man, the advanced computing technology in
the phone merges with Tom's brain to give
him superpowers. With those great powers,
he takes it as his responsibility to track
down the bad guys who nearly killed Lucy.
What if Baby Driver wasn't a soundtrack-driven
action comedy, and was instead an unpredictable,
intricately plotted suspense thriller about a
getaway driver having his worst ever day of work?
That's the logline for Wheelman, which also feels
like the greatest Jason Statham movie that Statham
never made. Frank Grillo portrays the unnamed,
unflappable wheelman in a bank heist scheme,
just out of prison and in debt to a Boston crime
family. Everything that could go wrong does,
but it's not all that funny — it's stressful
enough driving a getaway car for a robbery,
and it's even more nerve-wracking for the
wheelman when he gets more or less carjacked
by another band of mysterious criminals. Much
of the action takes place inside the car and
inside the head of the wheelman, speeding along
from one high-pressure situation to another.
James Badge Dale plays Clyne, one of the smartest
people in the world. Clyne is a DARPA scientist
employed by the U.S. military to develop weapons
technology to use in the ongoing Moldovan War in
Eastern Europe. He's summoned to the front lines
to consult on some strange findings captured
by one of his best gadgets, hyper-spectral
goggles. It would seem some troops wearing
the goggles spotted some ghostly figures out in
the wild that tend to kill whatever they come in
contact with. Before the military can report to
their higher-ups, they need Clyne to figure out
just what it is, and so off he goes into the war
zone to stalk the beast alongside a special ops
team and a C.I.A. operative. What they find
is way worse and more complicated than they
thought possible. A harrowing war movie with
elements of District 9 and Predator thrown in,
Spectral is clever, intense, and worth a watch.
Yes, there's a sequel to 2000's Crouching Tiger,
Hidden Dragon. And, like so many other revivals
of classic properties, it's just hanging out on
Netflix. Loosely based on the same "Crane-Iron"
series of books by Wang Dulu as the original
Crouching Tiger, Sword of Destiny builds on its
predecessor's magical combination of folk tales,
multi-faceted characters, and physically
impossible acrobatic fight scenes. Michelle
Yeoh returns as You Shu Lien, fresh out of
exile and locked in an important battle with
the West Lotus clan for control of the
Green Destiny sword. Directing Sword of
Destiny is Woo-Ping Yuen, the martial arts
choreographer on the first Crouching Tiger,
and he certainly brings his prowess for creating
gorgeous and soaring aerial combat sequences.
Why are period horror films so much
scarier than ones set in the modern
day? Is it because the relative ignorance and
brutality of the past adds an extra element
of terror? Or are images of Victorian-era
Londoners in bleak clothes living bleak
lives inherently unsettling? Probably
that, although blood-hungry monsters,
freaky islands, and blood cults are scary too.
Fortunately, Apostle possesses all those things.
Set in 1905, Apostle concerns a man named Thomas,
who leaves London for an island run by a cult
that's kidnapped his sister. Thomas poses as a new
adherent to gain favor with the cult members and
their leader, in the hopes of rescuing his sister
from them. However, things get awfully sticky for
Thomas when he realizes that the cult's teachings
aren't exactly wrong. Imagine if Little Shop of
Horrors mashed up with The Wicker Man, only
ten times as freaky, and you'll get Apostle.
There's always room for a new twist and
new voices in even the most trope-heavy
film genres. Take Cargo, which revives
the zombie movie genre from its funk
by adding new dimensions of humanity.
Directors Yolanda Ramke and Ben Howling
based the film on their 2013 short of the
same name. It follows a man named Andy,
played by Martin Freeman, who, with his wife
and infant daughter, preserves himself up in a
houseboat along a river deep in the interior
of Australia following a zombie apocalypse.
Andy wants to take the boat upriver to the
safety of military protection; his wife wants
to make a supply run. Eventually, Andy heads
out on land with Rosie strapped to his back,
fighting off the undead. Ultimately, Cargo
is a film about the will to not just survive,
but to protect your loved
ones, no matter the cost.
I Am Mother, the feature debut by writer-director
Grant Sputore, takes place after an apocalyptic,
extinction-level event has wiped out all
of humanity. Fortunately, a repopulation
contingency plan springs into action: a robot
named Mother activates in a secure lab facility
and raises one of 63,000 human embryos pre-frozen
by scientists should life ever cease to exist.
Mother then raises her human daughter, helpfully
named Daughter, through a pleasant childhood…
until things get prickly during the teen
years. Daughter discovers a living mouse
and wonders if there's more life beyond her four
walls. But then she finds out there really is,
when an adult human woman comes knocking at
the facility door. I Am Mother is ultimately
a thrilling, chilling, and even oddly touching
allegory about parenthood and letting go.
The Wandering Earth is one of the highest-grossing
movies of the decade… but most North American
movie fans probably have no idea it even exists.
It enjoyed an extremely small release in the U.S.,
but earned nearly $700 million at China's
box office. The film is one of that country's
first Hollywood-style, big-budget, blockbuster
science-fiction epics. In The Wandering Earth,
scientists discover that the sun is evolving
into a red giant, meaning that it's expanding
at a rate that will devour Earth in 100 years
and the entire solar system within 300 years.
The globe's governments and scientists work
together and come up with a creative solution:
10,000 gigantic jet engines are installed
around the world, propelling the planet out
of its orbit to begin a very long journey to a new
permanent resting spot more than four lightyears
away. Things go wrong relatively early when
spaceship Earth gets caught in Jupiter's orbit,
which will ensure its eventual destruction —
if our heroes can't get the jets working again,
that is. Comparable to Armageddon, The
Core, and Interstellar, The Wandering Earth
is a fun and accessible sci-fi adventure.
Filmmakers can use the limitless tools and
imagination of science fiction to say something
about the world, and Stefon Bristol explores some
powerful themes with See You Yesterday. Bristol
and his talented young cast combine sci-fi tropes
with brutal social commentary — this time-travel
thriller is about the future and the past,
but really it's about the present.
C.J., played by Eden Duncan-Smith,
is a precocious and preternaturally gifted
young scientist who, with her best friend
and collaborator Sebastian, has constructed a
rudimentary — but functional — time machine.
They just want to go back in time by a
day to look around and then come back,
so as not to "butterfly effect" the past and
rewrite history. But See You Yesterday is set
in the predominantly African-American
Brooklyn neighborhood of Flatbush,
and C.J's brother Calvin is horrifyingly shot
down in the street by the police. C.J. has to
use her device to go back and attempt to save
her brother's life while battling against the the
time loops and complications she both causes and
encounters. See You Yesterday is a heartbreaking,
thoughtful movie, one that's laced with great
sci-fi references as well as the Jamaican
influence that permeates Flatbush culture.
Don't waste any more time — see this movie.